it's
all right
so we know he's got an upward energy
followed by a downward energy
okay so I can't catch it on the way down
that's a young young
class and We're Dreaming if we think
we're going to catch it from
behind okay so what I
mean is you're not going to cut it
down do it again you're not going to cut
it
down got it I'll show you what you let's
see cut it down that's it okay so I'm
not going to hit him
[Applause]
so
someone explained to me
why you're never going to cut it from
the
top after it
passes it's too fast it's too fast okay
what makes it too fast is it is it my
inate
talent right and you're only only if I
was faster I could do it okay so what is
stacking those odds against me you're
chasing it okay you're chasing it so
let's use more of our
language are you action or reaction
reaction your reaction okay we know
there's like some on some people it's a
a whole second and 3/4 time for you to
put your
processing into some sort of Defense
okay on the best of us it's 3/4 of a
second reaction time you're just not
it's not going to happen happen it's not
going to happen Okay and hence
colloquially you're chasing it okay so
now you are
not uh you're not action you're reaction
you're also not
initiative you're all you're just going
to lose okay so we
can't clash with
it and we can't supposedly blend with it
okay on the Y
part also am
I
isi
[Music]
ywn and is ten con Yin isn't that how it
goes so if I'm to me then I'm young and
I have to blend with him so when do I
make contact with him as he comes up as
he's coming up because that's the in
phase of shui the Y phase is the
down so to enter I have to go with him
okay and then just like
KES I'm not going to be on the 180 I'm
turning the fight
okay so when I come up I turn him as an
extension of his upward Miss and now
instead of on K where the right
hand goes
here from
contact and my knees just turn in
place go
back the right knee is going to go
forward and pass to the head you're in
shikaku here's your
PIN rewind the film
give me your hand this was
KES okay in KES it's not that I pick up
his hand he picked up his hand and I
blended with
it he picks up his head and I blend with
it so up with him turn him
enter PIN his head smash it bam he gets
up bring it for
forward
extend smash so you have all your cou
here try to pick up your head it's not
going to do it but I blend with him
okay let's look at
the tering arm so where am I I'm over
here the angle canellation on this arm
is on the outside it's not on the top on
the top he can strike
on the top he can do he can do all kinds
of things at the lower level if he drops
to get on you're on the outside so he
tries to drop you're still
checking you're on this side we already
know that hand's going to go down right
cuz it's striking it has a y face to
complete you see fast fast your fastest
fastest I can stay
there I come here on the top he goes
down and you're going to lose it okay
and it doesn't do anything for you
you're going to buypass arm fighting arm
fighting is low percentage so you come
to a direct control of his spine you're
here protecting your area not here
trying to tilt him here attack the head
and stay in back of that shoulder in the
shikaku you stay back here you see and
there's your angle cancellation on that
other
arm he comes up take him forward you
stay in this back
corner we did this technique on on on
taking o sensei's you yield to another
level so he comes up and I go here this
leg's now in the way this leg you're
going to want to
open does he go this way no or this way
this way so you pull on his
spine again turn I'm on the outside
attacking the arm once I'm in shikaku
that arms irrelevant here's your angle
cancellation on that arm so this is your
guard hand not floating back here doing
nothing boom he comes up I take it
Forward I get my leg leg out of the way
and I take it on the figure
eight
turn pass I guarded myself at this point
comes
up move your leg out of the way no out
of the
way this
way okay try it again